Speaker 1: Pharmaceutical company Pfizer says
that an oral drug for covid-19 could be ready
next year.
Pfizer is working on two antivirals, an oral
medication and an injectable.
The company started an early stage clinical
trial of the oral drug last month.
The drug blocks a critical enzyme that the
virus needs to replicate.
It's very interesting.
Here is Pfizer CEO Albert Ballah talking about
this this morning on CNBC
Speaker 3: around this summer.
What do you think is a reasonable time frame
for a small molecule antiviral pill like that
to get through phase three and actually to
get out there and potentially be available
if all goes well?
Speaker 6: If all goes well and we implement
the same speed that we did so far, and we
are, and if regulators also do the same and
they are, I hope by by the end of the year,
Speaker 1: in this next clip, they talk about
the oral versus the injectable.
And again, this is Albert Albert Bourla, CEO
of Pfizer, who made 18 million dollars in
total compensation in 2019.
Let's listen.
Speaker 7: Albert is in a New York paper,
The Post bet covid cure may be ready this
year from the Pfizer drug.
And it's it's a I know you know which one
I'm talking about.
PAF zero seven three two one three three two
is what it said.
But it prevents a replication of of covid
in the nose and it could be an oral medication.
And they're calling it a cure.
Could be ready next year.
Is that headline accurate?
Speaker 6: Well, it is accurate that we are
working in on Devourer and we're not sure
until one of these insects and the other one,
as you I said, it is an oral and particularly
the intention is on the origin of the present
of us because provide several advantages.
And one of them is that you don't need to
go to the hospital to get the treatment, which
is the case with all the insects so far.
But you can get the call if that could be
a game changer.
The compound that you're are talking about
and you said, well, the numbers it is a protease
inhibitor is a good thing.
It is.
This is also the first molecule that is coming
from this type of class.
This is a good thing because you can combine
it with other.
Also, the mechanism of action is such that
it's not expected to be subject to mutations,
particularly because it's not acting on the
spike.
As we all know, all the mutations that we
are hearing right now are changes in the province
of the spine.
Speaker 1: So this is not a trivial detail.
An antiviral like what is being developed
by Pfizer would not be as jeopardized by mutations
and variants.
That's really important.
And of course, if all goes as described and
there's still much to be determined here,
this could be a real game changer.
Now, I have to tell you, it is not lost on
me that as Albert Bourla is speaking, the
stock price of Pfizer is on the screen as
their CEO is talking about medications they
may soon have.
This is a really stark reminder of the system
that we have, and I have addressed this before.
I believe there has to be a middle ground
here.
On the one hand, we can't allow pharmaceutical
companies to hold us hostage when it comes
to our health.
On the other hand, I don't expect the best
and brightest minds to line up to solve our
problems as a charitable contribution.
I just don't expect that to happen.
The creators of these treatments, vaccines,
et cetera, should be rewarded.
They really have done something incredible
that the Turkish couple in Germany who developed
what is now called the Pfizer vaccine, they
make a profit by doing this, they will then
be likely to do it again and they will be
more likely to come up with other cures, treatments,
vaccines when the next pandemic comes around.
If there is no profit now, who will invest
next time?
For now, Pfizer has increased revenue about
two percent.
After investing about 10 billion researching
the vaccine, they took some risk of investing
in a covered vaccine.
They could have done oncology stuff which
has higher profit margin.
The same applies to the researchers.
The founders of biotech are now really wealthy.
But don't we want people to enter the field
of science and develop things that can be
lifesaving?
But we need to ensure access.
We need to look at government subsidies.
And there there's a concept in health care
where premiums can't exceed benefits by a
certain percentage or a portion of the premiums
have to be refunded to the consumer.
Maybe allowing pharmaceutical companies to
have a margin that's fair, but limited would
work.
I don't know.
I'm just thinking out loud.
There are certain people I don't mind seeing
being paid handsomely.
Right, Mike?
If I had kids, my kids, teachers and doctors,
firefighters, people develop developing vaccines
to deal with a pandemic.
Should the government be involved in determining
a fair price?
Yeah, maybe so.
But context is crucial here.
Bernie Sanders made a statement about this
and he made a statement about vaccine production
and delivery outside the US and allowing other
countries to use the IP, the intellectual
property of US companies to make vaccines.
And instead of having to wait around for the
U.S. companies, those are great ideas.
The government should be involved.
But in a sense, I am more pleased with people
involved in biomedical research making money
than in some other areas.
Now, does the CEO deserve 18 million?
That's a very different question and one that
that I think we can fairly debate.
And the counter is always, well, if you only
pay two million, then some mining company
will swoop them up, sweep them up instead
of a pharmaceutical company, and maybe the
pharmaceutical company will be slower and
OK, OK, there's maybe a debate there, but
I think that it has to be a middle path here.